[Music]
hey world-wide-web what's going on we
are here and we are live with my
favorite end of your tradition the 2018
HotList looking forward to what's coming
up in the world of movies music and TV
and again we are live so you can leave
your comments below we can discuss
everything i'm ash Crossan and i'll be
talking about movies I'm so Vishal I see
the music expert and I'm Liana Galera
talking about the biggest news in the
small screen that's right TV should we
start with TV right that's doing I'm so
excited because it is going to be a big
year in TV and I'm breaking it up into
three different sections for you guys to
get a little bit easier to digest first
up is gonna be the shows that we missed
in 2017 now these were shows that took
the year off and they're coming back for
their second or third season so we've
got West world finally coming back to
HBO for its second season when we last
left off you know the hosts were taking
control of the park and although I can't
smell what's gonna happen I will say
that everyone will be talking about it
you know you know I know some secrets Oh
keep it locked of course to ET online
because we will be spilling little
details along the way but I'm so excited
because also Atlanta is coming back
which means we get more Donald Glover in
our lives and American crime story is
finally coming back and I'm sure it's
gonna snag a lot of awards show love
now this one is focusing on the
assassination of Gianni Versace and it's
got some big star power right Cruz yes
it's pretty Donatella Versace and she
looks amazing she looks awesome 'is that
what cast looks incredible oh my gosh
Ricky Martin's yeah so in it know about
you but of course I've got to talk about
unreal we mentioned this on last year's
hot list decided I was unreal was coming
back for season three and then it got
pushed so it's been more than a year
since we saw the show that's about the
behind the scenes of making a reality
show and now we're finally gonna catch
up with them
so those are the shows that we were
missing in 2017 now it's moving on to
the original yet not so original
revivals reboots and spin-offs every
year I feel like there's a good list
yeah and what's so funny is that we had
Will and Grace of course in 2017 and
getting awards show love so maybe
Roseann will be able to do the same
thing that show the whole dysfunctional
family is coming back so curious about
this right right so it's a TDD date we
don't know much about it but I do know
that ABC is completely jumping on the
revivals and reboots train because in
addition to Roseanne they're doing a two
spin-offs actually a grey's Anatomy's
spin-off and it's untitled we don't know
much about it but we do know that it's
going to be about firefighters which
okay Jed what Jason George is reviving
his role that we've known and loved on
Grey's Anatomy so things are heating up
with him pun intended should be here all
day and then there's also grown --is--
which is actually gonna be on freeform
which is the blackest spin-off and so
Zoe is going off to college and I think
that this is a perfect thing for
freeform to do because you know they're
taking an established show on ABC and
putting it on their little sister
network so because I'm fine yeah really
cute but the revival that I'm most
excited about is Heather's based off of
the iconic 80s movie it's so amazing and
so it's being revived on the Paramount
Network which is a brand new network
that we're gonna get to know three brand
new Heather's are terrorizing the spool
and shannen doherty is actually involved
in the project and she was an original
Heather yeah so perform Queens like nod
to Heather so okay so and this one
actually is gonna be able to cuss
because they have a really late time
slot so they're really pushing those
cable boundaries so kids to bed exactly
I'm always on board for a show with some
costume exactly exactly
you run Showtime so yeah well and lastly
these are brand new shows that I know
that you guys are going to love first up
is a CW show called life sentence and
it's Lucy Hales first post pretty little
liars show okay and so it's about a girl
who has lived with her whole life having
cancer she finds out she's been cured
and then she finds out that her whole
life is one big lie that her family's
been keeping up this happy facade to try
and make her get better and now that she
is everything falls apart they're not
actually really sweet we also have two
amazing shows that I'm so excited about
good girls on NBC which you ready
this red is coming back to TV yeah right
upper parts and rugrat Hendricks from
Mad Men and Mae Whitman who you guys
will know and love from the duck I just
all of those ladies exactly exactly I'm
so excited so good girls it's about
three regular moms who robbed a grocery
store and of course chaos ensues we have
sharp objects coming to HBO which is the
next big little lies mark my words okay
Ron Gillian Flynn who you guys know
wrote gone girl and it stars Amy Adams
it's gonna be eight episodes and I don't
know if it'll be like big little lies
and come back for a surprise second
season who knows HBO and the last show
that I'm really excited about because I
know that Sophie's gonna love it because
it involves music it's called rise it's
coming to NBC and it's from executive
producer Jason Katims he did Friday
Night Lights and Parenthood and so it
stars Josh Radnor who's Ted from How I
Met Your Mother
yes the leading lady from Moana and
who's meme that I always watch her
allahi Cavalli oh I I'm sorry I thought
about thank you she's amazing no
parabens we'll get there incredible and
Shannon purser from stranger things
who's awesome my girl no good
I messed up Conor barb she's yeah
Shannon she's dead a but basically if
you were to take Friday Night Lights and
Glee and it had like a really gritty but
awesome baby that'd be rice okay I'm
intrigued
yes yeah I'm ready for it oh gosh I'm at
a black big year big year for TV
you